December 26th 2011 NASA's Terra
satellite passes high over the South
Atlantic Ocean and captures this image
it appears to be a giant whirlpool of
glowing blue light I've seen ocean
whirlpools before but I've never seen
anything on this scale before who or
what is actually making this sign up you
can't believe that this is actually
something that exists for real in the
ocean the whirlpool or whatever it is is
located 500 miles off the coast of South
Africa
and it's huge stretching as far as a
hundred miles the image seems to
indicate a whirlpool the size of an
entire state well that's pretty scary
but it's not just the scale that's
astonishing analysts why is this thing
whatever it is glowing blue one possible
reason that you might be able to see
this phenomenon in the photograph is
because this ocean for text has sucked
up millions upon millions of
microorganisms otherwise known as
phytoplankton phytoplankton are
organisms that emit a bright blue light
everything in these ocean vortexes are
trapped so they're spinning and have
millions of billions of gallons of water
wearing plankton debris and they're
moving across oceans from continent to
continent and nothing gets out
but it's just a theory no one has seen
anything quite like this before
a massive ocean vortex if that's what it
is can be created by an earthquake on
the ocean floor
on March 11th 2001 a magnitude 9
earthquake takes place 43 miles off the
coast of Japan
the result one of the biggest tsunamis
ever recorded
waves 130 feet high pummel Japan's
mainland
creating deadly whirlpools along the
coast which suck fishing boats down
beneath the waves
but these whirlpools are tiny in
comparison to the glowing monster
captured on satellite
and no tsunami or earthquake has been
recorded off the coast of South Africa
the blue spiral of light caught on
satellite camera looks like something
from a sci-fi movie analysts have not
encountered anything quite like this
before it looks too big to be a
whirlpool there have been no recorded
earthquakes in the area and there are no
unusual weather reports from shipping in
the region the blue vortex remains a
mystery